vous en souvenez peut-être le 20 mars
dernier
paris battait un record c'était pas un
record d'essais encaissés ce n'était pas
un record de prix de l'immobilier ni
même un record de bouchons
le 20 mars dernier paris a battu un
record de pollution alors c'est un
record dont on se passerait bien
mais pendant près de 24 heures l'air de
la capitale et est plus pollué que nous
les l'air de pékin moyenne sur toute
l'année ça paraît invraisemblable
dit comme ça et pourtant les chiffres le
montrent cette courbe que vous voyez
derrière moi c'est le taux de particules
fines dans l'air de la capitale
ces particules fines ce sont ces petits
bouts de matières en suspension
microscopique de quelques microns il
rentre à travers la barrière sanguine
dans les poumons dans notre corps et
créer des crises d'asthme
il déclenche des problèmes
cardiovasculaires à long terme ils
peuvent permettre de développer des
cancers et ces particules fines
ce sont celles qui bouchent la vue
finalement qui créent ces nuages en
suspension qui faisait disparaître la
tour eiffel alors le 18 mars deux jours
avant mon équipe et moi réalisant que la
pollution à paris était en train de
passer devant pékin au même moment
avions tiré l'alertent et puis tout
s'est emballé à partir d'un tweet y en a
eu plusieurs
puis beaucoup puis des radios qui
appelait le soir le matin des journaux
puis ensuite de quelques exagérations
on a lu que paris était la ville la plus
polluée du monde alors qu'évidemment il
ya des villes où on ne mesure même pas
l'air qu'on respire mais surtout pendant
que c'est débat faisait rage
la pollution elle continue à monter et
le 20 mars
la concentration de particules fines à
paris a dépassé la moyenne annuelle
qu'on observe à pékin c'est même au delà
des normes sanitaires maximale fixée par
le gouvernement chinois
alors autant vous dire que l'ère de la
capitale si vous étiez là vous en
souvenez sans doute
et puis c'est débat qui a fait rage sur
ce qu'on pouvait y faire avec la durée
des jours et des jours et des jours et
au moment
ou finalement les pouvoirs publics ont
pris la décision de mettre en place ce
qu'on appelle la circulation alternée à
la pollution elle était déjà en train de
s'en aller et avant de la mettre en
application
trente six heures après et bien
finalement le taux de pollution qu'on
avait observé était déjà un lointain
souvenir
si ce n'est un lointain cauchemar
évidemment on peut faire mieux et ma
conviction c'est qu'on doit faire mieux
on ne peut plus se contenter de ce type
de réponse qui viennent trop tard qu'ils
sont finalement beaucoup trop peu et
puis surtout qu'ils ne répondent pas à
l'enjeu de long terme que représente la
pollution de l'air que l'on respire
parce que la pollution c'est un problème
d'environnement qui est liée au
changement climatique
mais surtout c'est un problème de santé
les proportions que prennent l'impact de
la qualité de l'air sur notre santé sont
aujourd'hui digne d'une véritable
épidémie mondiale
d'après l'organisation mondiale de la
santé c'est près de 7 millions de
personnes à travers le monde chaque
année qui décèdent des causes directes
ou indirectes de l'air que l'on respire
de la pollution atmosphérique de la
qualité de l'air en intérieur évidemment
ce sont des chiffres immense évidemment
ça inclut une partie du monde émergent
l'inde la chine on connaît les
difficultés que la pollution représente
messi aussi un problème à paris le
simple fait comme sans doute nous tous
ici de vivre à paris d'avoir fait le
choix s'installer dans la capitale
ça veut dire six mois d'espérance de vie
en moins à cause de ces particules fines
et puis le coût humain que représente la
pollution de le coût pour la santé le
coût pour notre bien-être poursuivre nos
enfants mais finalement c'est un coût
qui se chiffrent et c'est un coup aussi
économique et le sénat cet été a estimé
que près de 97 milliards d'euros étaient
perdus chaque année par l'économie
française à cause de l'air que l'on
respire à cause de la pollution qu'on
s'inflige parce que évidemment baisser
les coûts pour la santé sont des coûts à
long terme des maladies chroniques qui
vont durer sur toute notre vie et puis
ce sont des coupes tout simplement pour
les entreprises parce que quand on est
malade on est absent et donc la
pollution
ça coûte et ça coûte beaucoup c'est un
tiers quasiment de la dette grecque tous
les ans qui partent littéralement en
fumée donc on peut pas continuer comme
ça et heureusement ce soir je ne viens
pas apporter de mauvaises nouvelles ou
essayer de vous faire
j'ai cherché à porter un message
d'espoir malgré des apparences un
message d'espoir parce que la pollution
c'est donc un problème d'environnement
un problème de santé mais pour nous
c'est d'abord un problème d'information
un problème d'information parce qu'en
fait la pollution on a du mal à s'en
protéger parce qu on la comprend mal les
chercheurs comprennent encore mal
l'impact de la pollution sur la santé
évidemment pour le grand public
comprendre les différents polluants
comment est-ce qu'ils vont impacter son
bien-être c'est quelque chose qui
demande de s'y intéresser de s'y
informer sa demande de comprendre les
sciences atmosphériques la chimie des
différences entre les particules fines
ozone lennox des composés organiques
volatils et puis tous ces composants ont
des sources très diverses qui varie en
plus
heure par heure par heure d'une rue à
l'autre d'une ville et donc la
variabilité de ce phénomène fait qu'il
est très difficile à comprendre et puis
comme en plus la pollution
c'est invisible la plupart du temps sauf
quand la tour eiffel disparaît eh bien
on a bien du mal à son protégé
mais la bonne nouvelle c'est que puisque
avec un peu plus d'information on
pourrait savoir à quoi on s'expose et
donc agir pour le réduire
la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce problème
est un problème d'information or les
problèmes d'information en 2015 le 21
octobre dans le futur donc on sait les
résoudre on sait les résoudre grâce aux
technologies de l'information justement
on sait les raisons de grâce à l'open
data l'accès aux données publiques que
collecte les gouvernements à travers la
planète sur l'état de nos sociétés nos
économies notre environnement est donc
plutôt qu'attendre que nos villes un
jour peut-être deviennent respirable
nous avons décidé tout de suite
aujourd'hui de créer nous mêmes notre
première solution pour mieux se protéger
de la pollution et c'est pour ça que
j'ai créé plume labs une start up qui
vous aident à respirer qui collectent
l'ensemble des données à travers le
monde sur l'état
la qualité de l'air pour permettre à
chacun d'améliorer son bien être sa
santé en étant informés sur ce qu'il
respire et donc grâce à cette plateforme
de données qui à travers le monde plus
de onze mille stations un demi million
de points de mesures tous les jours
construit cette météo en temps réel de
la pollution on a pu développer ce qu'on
appelle une intelligence artificielle
environnemental c'est à dire un ensemble
de modèles mathématiques qu'on entraîne
pour
puisse prévoir la façon dont l'air va
évoluer et ça ça fait toute la
différence
parce que grâce à notre application
mobile vous avez effectivement la météo
de la pollution dans votre ville dans la
paume de la main et donc vous savez
comment dans les heures qui viennent la
qualité de l'air va évoluer vous pouvez
adapter votre comportement et puisqu'on
rend visible un phénomène qui ne l'est
pas vous allez pouvoir éviter de vous y
exposer sans de savoie et donc
concrètement laurent avec qui je vais
courir de temps en temps dans les bois
parisiens peut choisir leur optimale
pour faire son footing et éviter d'aller
courir pile au moment où l'air qu'ils
respirent serait le plus mauvais
stéphane qui vit entre paris le danemark
la chine l'indonésie
grâce aux données sur 200 villes à
travers la planète dans près de 30 pays
est capable de savoir quels sont les
moments où la pollution est trop élevé
et à quel moment il peut au contraire ne
plus s'en préoccuper et puis eva qui
élèvent benjamins 2 ans en plein coeur
de paris et qui se pose évidemment de la
question de ce que ça peut avoir comme
impact sur sa santé elle peut suivre
heure par heure les évolutions de la
pollution évitée de l'amener au square
au moment où la pollution est en plein
pic alors c'est de l'information de ce
n'est que de l'information mais c'est
déjà essentiel parce que ça permet
d'agir parce que ça permet de se
protéger et grâce aux technologies nous
pouvons dès aujourd'hui nos protégés et
puis demain avec le développement de
capteurs personnel que l'on met au point
avec le cnrs on pourra chacun savoir
quels sont les moments les endroits des
contextes dans lesquels on est exposé et
puis comment éviter de faire de notre
environnement qui aujourd'hui la
première préoccupation des français
première préoccupation environnementale
des français c'est la qualité de l'air
un levier de problèmes de santé est une
cause finalement 2d confort et de
développement à long terme de problèmes
chroniques qui ont un coût encore une
fois non seulement pour chacun d'entre
nous mais surtout pour nous tous
et puis pour aller plus loin bien sûr
les technologies vont nous aider à
rendre nos villes plus respirable
demain le covoiturage les voitures
électriques l'ensemble des
technologiques on voit émerger et qu'on
va voir aujourd'hui vont nous permettre
en fait de moins polluer dans nos
centres villes et donc de mieux y
respirer mais la technologie
y sont l'humain ça n'est rien pour agir
d'abord seul puis ensuite ensemble
grâce à ces technologies nous allons
nous devoir faire des choix collectifs
des choix politiques et des choix
politiques c'est compliqué ça suppose de
se mettre d'accord ça suppose de se
mettre même d'accord sur le fait qu'il y
a un problème et qu'il faut le régler et
puis surtout ça suppose de mobiliser de
marquer les esprits alors on l'a vu le
simple données peuvent faire émerger un
débat de société autour d'une ville d'un
pays entier mais mobilisé ça doit se
faire dans la durée
ça doit se faire sur le long terme et
donc ça ne peut pas simplement être une
question de technologie
c'est une question aussi qui concerne
chacun d'entre nous quelles sont les
conditions que l'on accepte dont nous
ville aujourd'hui comment voulons nous
réinventer notre santé de demain grâce à
un meilleur environnement et donc ce
record finalement en tant que parisien
évidemment j'en suis bien désolé mais en
tant qu'entrepreneur et en tant que
citoyen j'ai la fierté de l'avoir fait
connaître d'avoir participé à faire
émerger une réponse et puis surtout
grâce à ses données de rendre l'air que
l'on respire à paris somme toute un tout
petit peu plus transparent
merci beaucoup